in this part of ajiya county there is
nothing left to eat for abdirahman
hussein abdi's remaining cattle nearly
every day he wakes up to this
his animals are wasting away and dying
from hunger and disease
he says his prized bull the wood on a
good day cost around seven hundred
dollars does not have long to leave
either most of the animals here in
northeastern kenya are in poor condition
he's desperate
we're struggling of 700 cattle for three
families there's only 300 left they're
malnourished the ones that appear
healthy just drop i'm not sure what's
affecting them
another village many kilometers away
shabbat nizak is just getting back home
from a four-hour trek to fetch water for
his family and the sheep and goats he
desperately needs to keep alive
dead and dying livestock scatter his
compound
for seven months we've been fetching
water from very far away
malnutrition rates continue to rise
children are receiving emergency food
supplies from aid agencies
our children are affected they get sick
often we hope to get more food for them
many people are suffering from the
drought
the local government is distributing hay
nutritional livestock pellets as well as
transporting water to the most remote
villages but the need is too great
harders from different communities
across the region come to watering
points such as this one to share the
resource but because of the drought the
water is running low so is pasture and
government officials tell us they're
overwhelmed
the drought in parts of kenya wasn't by
climate change has been declared a
national disaster
here in wajeer past released tell us it
has not rained for the last two years
where the casters say the current short
reigns will not help much
the food security currently is
in the third phase what they call
critical
and if we may
not receive
adequate rainfall in the coming few days
then definitely it's not something we
can handle as a county the resources we
have is very limited
times are hard even for the most
resilient of animals
rare wildlife species found only in this
part of the country are also succumbing
to hunger thirst and exhaustion
back in the village abdirahman hussein
tells us he's helpless as he watches his
animals die every day
catherine soy al jazeera would year
north eastern kenya